foreign
news now investigators learning a woman
is facing new DUI charges after getting
arrested hours after completing a
sentence in a prior DUI case her license
was revoked just this weekend another
department says it happened again a news
now investigator David Charles here with
why she's out of jail tonight David yeah
Brian Denise I think what is most
shocking here is we've learned police
arrested this driver hours after she had
just left court to close out a different
DUI case today in court a judge let her
out because he said prosecutors hadn't
yet filed the necessary paperwork
so I'm assuming you're not asking me the
older any longer right um Marion Reyes
Rivero appearing in front of a judge
again police in Henderson arresting her
Thursday officers say Reyes Rivera was
driving Under the Influence with a
suspended license records the eight news
now investigators obtained indicate that
license was pulled in June by August
CCSD police had arrested Reyes Rivero
for another DUI her sixth DUI arrest
since 2007 in that August case police
pulled Reyes Rivera over just after 10
in the morning just hours earlier at 7
30 Reyes Rivero was in court to close
out an earlier DUI case record showing
she had just completed a 10-week program
it has escalated worse than we have seen
it in quite a number of years Cindy
heverly is the executive director of
stop DUI a non-profit aimed at Curbing
and pair driving and helping Victor
items of the crime she says she's not
surprised somebody with a revoked
license is driving and says with fewer
officers on the road amid a state police
Staffing crisis the problem is only
getting worse this is the bottom line
she had access to probably a four
thousand pound weapon that's what it
comes down to heavily says it's
outrageous Reyes Rivera is out of jail
awaiting her next court appearance
people's lives are going to be at risk
for as long as she's out and about
people like that need to be taken off
the street for as long as possible the
judge noting this you can't drive you
understand I understand uh no driving
whatsoever
keep in mind a different judge had told
her that before prosecutors saying they
needed this additional time as they were
awaiting test results from that latest
DUI arrest and because the judge had
nothing to hold her on the law requires
that defendant's release the judge
saying that could all change though at
the next Hearing in two weeks I'm David
charns 8 News Now